Salut, moi, c'est Guillaume Hachez. Bienvenue dans Septante Minutes Avec. Très très heureux de vous retrouver cette semaine pour ce quinzième épisode de Septante Minutes Avec.
Très heureux pour deux raisons. D'abord parce que l'émission fête aujourd'hui ses six mois. Six mois, c'est pas énorme, mais mine de rien, c'est quand même une milestone.
Il y a eu beaucoup de chemin parcouru en six mois, des invités absolument délicieux et des auditeurs tout à fait charmants, que je ne mérite absolument pas.
Un tout grand merci à vous. Et puis surtout, je reçois cette semaine Rudy Léonet, qui anime avec Hugues Dayez l'émission Cinq Heures Cinéma, qui est un de mes podcasts préférés.
Et c'est aussi le tout premier auquel je me suis abonné il y a dix ans. Une grande valeur sentimentale pour moi donc, mais pas seulement, puisque dans cet épisode, on parle surtout de l'industrie musicale et de son évolution à l'ère du numérique.
Rudy est un expert en la matière. Il a longtemps été critique musical. Il a dirigé Pure FM, la radio jeune de la RTBF pendant douze ans.
Et pour l'anecdote, il a aussi signé plusieurs textes pour le groupe Indochine. Un petit préambule pour nos amis qui sont à l'étranger.
Les dix premières minutes sont assez belgo-belges, mais je vous rassure, ça devient moins cryptique après. Allez, sans plus attendre, on retrouve Rudy Léonet.
C'est parti. Et bonjour à tous. Aujourd'hui, on passe septante minutes avec un homme qui est l'ancien directeur de Pure FM.
Il est aujourd'hui coordinateur éditorial trois cent soixante pour le sujet de la pop culture à la RTBF. On verra un petit peu ce que ça veut dire.
Chroniqueur occasionnel dans Matin Première, il se définit comme un homme de radio. Il a longtemps porté la casquette de critique musicale pour la RTBF et pour Moustique. Rudy Léonet, salut.
Hey, je commence comme toi par le hey.
Hey.
Salut.
Est-ce que tu te reconnais dans le portrait que j'ai fait de toi ?
Oh, plus ou moins, parce qu'entre temps, des choses ont déjà changé. Mon titre à la RTBF n'est plus exactement pareil. Je suis maintenant responsable coordinateur éditorial des opérations spéciales auprès de la Direction générale des médias.
J'ai déjà oublié.
Moi aussi. Mais les centres d'intérêt restent absolument identiques. Donc on est sur un terrain connu. Je valide.
J'allais dire, la première fois qu'on s'est vus, c'était quand j'avais été l'invité de Cinq Heures Cinéma, il y a quelques années pour une spéciale Star Wars.
Exact.
À ce moment-là, donc, tu étais encore le directeur de Pure FM. Aujourd'hui, ce n'est plus le cas.
Non.
Ton titre que tu viens de me donner et que j'ai déjà oublié, qu'est-ce que ça veut dire exactement ? Qu'est-ce que tu fais dans la vie ?
Ben en gros, à la RTBF, je m'arrange pour que des événements dont la récurrence n'est pas celle d'une grille des programmes.
Tu sais qu'en radio ou en télévision, les grilles de programmes ont un rythme, une récurrence qui est en radio quotidienne, hebdomadaire.
Au-delà, c'est compliqué. Des émissions mensuelles en radio, impossible de créer une fidélité. En télévision, ben la récurrence, elle est beaucoup plus large.
Effectivement, on est plus sur de l'hebdo, voire du bimensuel sur certaines émissions. Donc moi, je m'occupe de programmes qui ont lieu une fois par an ou en one shot.
Les une fois par an, c'est par exemple les Decibel Music Awards, les Magritte, la Fête de la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles, Grand-Place avec ce podium live, les festivals d'été.
Voilà. Et puis de temps en temps, des choses qui peuvent comme ça se présenter, s'allumer et s'éteindre, des émissions un petit peu pop-up, mais qui ne nécessitent pas un travail, je dirais,
structurel dans le cadre d'une grille et d'une récurrence.
D'accord, OK. Donc, tu es vraiment passé de animateur journaliste à backstage, analytics, on regarde les chiffres, on analyse les tendances.
Non, non, c'est pas que ça. C'est aussi essayer d'avoir une belle cohérence éditoriale sur les programmes qu'on met à l'antenne.
Dans le cadre des Decibel Music Awards, là, c'est encore autre chose. Il y a aussi un travail de coulisse qui est, je dirais, presque un travail de,
de greffier ou d'huissier ou de commissaire, à savoir de vérifier que le règlement est bien appliqué et qu'on ne fait pas rentrer dans les votes des artistes ou des albums qui ne seraient pas éligibles.
Pour les Magritte, c'est autre chose. On travaille avec toute une équipe pour recruter des remettants pour les prix.
Là, cette année, j'ai beaucoup travaillé avec Alex Vizorek, que j'avais été chercher pour présenter la cérémonie.
Ah, c'est toi qui l'as choisi ?
Oui. Il ne voulait pas. Et puis, parce qu'il avait déjà été sollicité par le passé pour plusieurs raisons. Parce que d'abord, il avait un agenda qui était bien bien bien rempli.
Et puis j'ai fini par le convaincre de le faire quand même. Et on s'est entouré, il s'est entouré.
Donc du coup, comme j'ai été adoubé dans l'aventure de façon très proche, on s'est retrouvés avec une équipe d'auteurs qui sont Christophe Bourdon, Pierre Chauret et Julien Demarche.
Et on a travaillé tous ensemble à la construction, à la rédaction et à écrire l'histoire de ces Magritte-là. Mais pour l'instant, je suis sur qui pour l'année prochaine, puisque-
C'est ça, déjà. Tu t'es déjà penché.
Alex veut reprendre. Ah oui, oui, oui. Donc quand tu disais tout à l'heure les chiffres, les audiences, l'analyse, oui, ça, c'est la partie, je dirais, en aval de ce qui a été proposé sur antenne.
Évidemment, on se voit pour débriefer et comment-
Et comment on peut identifier les forces et les faiblesses pour encore faire mieux la prochaine fois.
Donc il reste un aspect créatif et en plus de ça, il va sans dire que tu es aussi toujours l'animateur de, pardon, de Cinq Heures Cinéma.
Oui. Plus sur Pure FM d'ailleurs.
Oui, c'est ça. La Première.
Ça change tout.
Ça change tout. Oui, je me souviens que quand il y a eu le changement, c'est Hugues qui l'avait signalé dans le podcast.
Et toi, tu étais là un petit peu en mode : ça n'a aucune importance, il faut même pas en parler, c'est-
Mais c'est parce qu'en fait, de façon un peu spontanée, on avait annoncé ça lors de la dernière COD Live à Carnion.
Enfin, pour ceux qui suivent un peu, c'était le 22 décembre. On dit : Oui, on a des projets pour l'année prochaine et notamment, on va passer sur la Première.
Et on avait fait un flop genre- Ça ne signifiait pas grand-chose pour-
Le public n'applaudissait pas ou quoi ?
Non, enfin, je pense que c'était une non-information-
Le flux RSS reste le même en gros donc voilà.
Voilà, puisque de toute façon, c'est toujours le même format, c'est toujours la même récurrence, c'est toujours les deux mêmes vieux grincheux.
Voilà. Donc ça ne changeait pas grand-chose pour eux. Pour nous, ça change parce que l'environnement dans lequel on se retrouve aujourd'hui est un environnement qui est un terreau beaucoup plus favorable à de l'expansion.
Voilà. Pour résumer ma pensée, c'est la Première, Frank Guistas, pour ne pas le nommer, qui est le nouveau responsable édito de la Première qui est venu nous chercher. Et,
immédiatement, j'ai trouvé que c'était une bonne idée. D'abord, ça allait un peu nous bousculer,
sortir un peu de notre zone de confort et du ronron, à la fois pour nous et à la fois pour la chaîne qui nous accueillait et que j'avais créée en 2004.
Et que finalement, ce programme Cinq Heures avait été embarqué, compris dans le prix, moi étant le prix.
Ouais, c'est ça.
Mais à la longue, on était un peu comme une armoire normande qui prenait la poussière. La jeune génération qui arrive sur Pure ne sait pas qui on est.
Ce n'est pas un reproche.
Fanny sait très bien qui vous êtes. Fanny Ruwet, qui est animatrice et qui a seulement vingt-quatre ans, sait très bien qui vous êtes.
Oui, mais elle, c'est une marginale. Je parle de, voilà, de la grande majorité de ceux qui sont sur antenne. Ça ne les intéresse pas.
Donc, spontanément, c'est compliqué quand c'est un podcast qui est natif. Je suppose que tu sais de quoi je parle puisque tu en fais.
Et nos auditeurs savent de quoi on parle.
Voilà, faire vivre un podcast sans vitrine sur un média traditionnel et ne pas être juste un replay-
Oui
...d'un programme qui a existé en linéaire, c'était un peu compliqué. Et tout ce travail-là n'était pas-
Effectivement, vous avez une présence dans Matin Première maintenant avec des petits extraits rapidement.
Oui, on a eu un engouement de toute l'équipe de la Première, que ça soit effectivement Mehdi Kelfad, que ça soit François Heureux dans Jour Première, Jérôme Colin dans Entrez sans frapper, même l'équipe promo.
Voilà, tout le monde s'est réjoui de notre arrivée alors que nous, on trouvait que c'était une simple formalité administrative quoi.
Mais en fait, c'était beaucoup plus que ça. Et voilà, on s'est senti bien accueilli et soutenu. Et ça se remarque déjà dans les audiences du podcast-
Ah ouais ? Ça augmente ?
Oui, qui reprend des couleurs après avoir eu un passage un peu... Je ne vais pas dire un passage à vide parce que-
Ça se souffle un peu quoi.
Ben, c'est-à-dire que oui, à un moment donné, il y a une espèce d'érosion comme ça inéluctable. Il n'y a rien à faire.
Si quelqu'un n'a plus d'oxygène pour respirer, à un moment donné, il tombe dans le coma. Voilà, donc voilà. Donc la respiration était un peu compliquée.
Là, ouf, ça va beaucoup mieux.
Ça reprend. Oui, mais c'est marrant parce que j'ouvrais le podcast en disant : Rudy Léonet, homme de radio. Donc on dit maintenant ton émission Cinq Heures Cinéma n'est plus en radio.
Tu n'es plus le directeur de Pure, tu animes un podcast. Est-ce qu'aujourd'hui, tu te reconnais encore dans, voilà, le paysage audiovisuel radiophonique en Belgique francophone ?
Ou bien est-ce qu'un peu à la manière de ce que Myriam Leroy nous disait il y a un mois, tu deviens de plus en plus plutôt un homme de podcast, un homme de streaming ?
Alors, il y a deux aspects. Enfin, il y a trois aspects à la question. Le premier : est-ce que je me reconnais dans le paysage audio ?
Je parle même pas de visuel, mais audio en Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles. Alors, je vais te répondre par une pirouette.
Quand je suis en voiture, je branche mon téléphone-
Ouais, le Bluetooth
...sur, voilà, sur mon autoradio et j'écoute des playlists Spotify. Deuxièmement, est-ce que faire du streaming, du podcast, est-ce que ce n'est pas s'écarter du métier de la radio quelque part ?
Ben, je vais te dire exactement le contraire. Je trouve que ça renoue, au contraire,
inversément aux idées reçues, ça renoue avec une certaine manière de faire de la radio qu'on a un petit peu perdue dans ce principe de faire de la radio linéaire en FM ou en DAB, peu importe aujourd'hui.
Le fait de prendre son temps, de ne pas être formaté, de ne pas être interrompu, soit par des infos routes, de la météo, des pubs, des infos.
Voilà, il y a une espèce de liberté de parole aussi, une grammaire radiophonique qu'on peut retrouver et qui est plutôt celle des années soixante ou septante que celle des années nonante ou 2000.
On retourne à une forme de radio qui est beaucoup plus traditionnelle, même si la manière de la diffuser, de la distribuer est digitale.
Le canal a changé, mais-
Le canal a changé. Voilà. On n'est plus dans du broadcast, on est dans du webcast, mais le process de fabrication est, lui, plutôt ancien.
Ça peut paraître moderne pour des gens qui n'ont jamais connu que des radios musicales formatées avec des jingles, des gens qui crient, qui disent que tout va bien, on est si bien ensemble.
Voilà. De retourner à un mode d'échange de paroles où on laisse beaucoup de temps à la parole et on prend le temps de s'expliquer avec une série d'arguments et d'éléments qui sont nécessaires à la réflexion.
On prend son temps, on n'est pas soumis à une sorte de diktat de format.
Ben, c'est une espèce de radio d'un autre temps, d'un autre âge, mais qui peut paraître révolutionnaire pour quelqu'un qui n'a jamais connu cette façon de faire de la radio en FM ou en AM par le passé.
C'est marrant parce que d'habitude, quand on parle de Spotify, on parle plus du côté algorithmique, le fait qu'on recommande tout, on reste un peu dans une bulle, on écoute un peu tout le temps la même chose.
Toi, tu mets plutôt en avant le côté éditorial, le fait qu'il existe des playlists qui sont-
Mais OK, mais ça, c'est- il y a des gens, ils vont s'acheter une voiture et c'est pour faire tout le temps le même trajet hein : chez eux, au Cora, du Cora à l'école, de l'école,
à la piscine, de la piscine chez eux et puis boulot, retour maison.
Voilà. Et ils font le circuit, voilà. Mais quand tu as une voiture, moi, je me souviens, à une époque, il y avait sur les voitures des autocollants où on mettait : « Ma voiture, c'est ma liberté ».
Enfin voilà. Bah, dès le moment où on a une sorte de mobilité, à chacun d'en profiter selon ses souhaits et selon ses appétences, selon ses envies.
Voilà. Spotify, c'est no limit quoi. Mais évidemment, si on veut rester dans un cercle de choses connues et qui rassurent, bah, c'est possible aussi, mais faire exploser la bulle pour aller chercher autre chose.
En plus, je trouve que leur algorithme est pas si idiot-
Oui, il y a de temps en temps des nouveautés hein.
Ouais, il y a des choses qui sont pas du tout inintéressantes et assez bien vues. On aurait presque l'impression que derrière ça, il y a quand même une--
je vais pas dire une intervention humaine ou une réflexion, mais en tout cas une espèce d'intuition-
Oui
...de sixième sens qui est assez bien vue.
Ouais, ouais, je suis assez d'accord là-dessus. Mais c'est intéressant parce que tu évoques un petit peu la comparaison entre d'un côté les plateformes de streaming, Spotify, Apple Music, etc.
Et de l'autre côté, la radio FM, tout va bien, il est 6 h, la météo, les infos trafic, etc.
Exact.
Donc, on le disait, en 2004, tu as créé Pure FM-
Oui
...sur les cendres de Radio 21, qui donc avait un public- c'était un peu la radio pop rock, mais avec un public trop large-
...18 plus. Et donc on a décidé de la couper en deux, avec d'un côté 18-34 ans pour Pure FM et de l'autre côté, peut-être un peu plus-
35, 55 et plus-
Oui, voilà, c'est ça pour le-
Classique 21.
C'est ça. Du vieux rock, entre guillemets. Je dis ça, mais en vrai, j'ai 24 ans et quand je me lave les dents, j'écoute classique, mais bon, soit.
Oui.
Parce que- donc au départ, tu n'avais pas proposé ta candidature pour la direction de Pure. Finalement, tu as choisi de le faire.
Qu'est-ce qui t'a amené donc à prendre cette décision, à te mettre en avant et à dire : « Moi, j'ai une vision pour la radio », en 2004 ?
Bah, je sais pas. Je crois que globalement, dans la vie, je ne suis pas quelqu'un de très ambitieux. Je n'ai pas une très haute opinion de mes capacités à faire quelque chose, voilà, tout simplement.
Et donc je m'étais dit : « Super, il y aura un nouveau projet, je m'inscrirai dedans ». Et pas mal de gens autour de moi m'ont dit : « Mais non, le projet, c'est toi.
Tu dois inscrire les autres dans un projet dont tu devras avoir la vision. À part toi, on voit personne pour le faire. Écris quelque chose, propose quelque chose ».
Et donc je suis parti sur une espèce de scénario fiction. S'il y avait une nouvelle radio, moi, je la verrais comme ci, comme ça.
Je mettrais ceci, cela-
C'est-à-dire, c'était quoi tes ambitions à ce moment-là ?
Bah, l'idée, c'était en fait d'essayer de coller davantage, avec une programmation musicale au réel centre d'intérêt des gens qui se déplacent et qui font l'effort d'aller voir des concerts.
C'était vraiment le retour à une radio pour les music lovers.
Tu estimais que Radio 21, c'était pas vraiment ça ?
Non, Radio 21 était une radio- oh là là, là, on remonte vraiment loin en arrière, mais une radio qui s'était construite un peu comme une couverture en patchwork quoi.
C'était toute une sorte de--
c'était des pièces rapportées. Il y avait tellement de différences entre ce que je pouvais faire dans Cinq Heures, le rock à gogo de Pompon, Cadence de Brigitte Graffey, les classiques de Marc le dimanche matin.
Enfin, tout ça faisait un ensemble mosaïque très intéressant-
Mais sans cohérence
...mais je ne pouvais pas- voilà, je ne pouvais pas croire qu'une seule personne écoutait tout ça.
Donc, c'est une grille qui était davantage construite comme une radio généraliste, d'où une audience qui était de plus en plus vieillissante sur Radio 21.
Et il était temps un petit peu de reclarifier les choses. Et l'idée a été effectivement de faire une musicale beaucoup plus adulte et une musicale jeune.
Sachant qu'une musicale adulte, bah, on est sur un travail de mémoire et de répertoire hein. Une fois qu'on a, entre guillemets, sa grande bibliothèque, bah, de temps en temps, avec le temps, on rajoute des choses.
Coldplay sera le classique de demain, Ed Sheeran aussi, voilà. Mais on ne prend pas beaucoup de risques.
C'est plutôt une radio de répertoire qui rassure.
Nostalgique un peu.
Oui, c'est ce qui explique, je pense, aujourd'hui, dans une époque qui est un peu chahutée, qui est une époque pleine d'incertitudes et assez angoissante, se replie sur des valeurs sûres et des valeurs,
des valeurs cocoons, des valeurs qui sont rassurantes.
Oui, réécouter ce qu'on connaît déjà et ce qui a déjà fait ses preuves, c'est ce qu'on appelle des points chauds en radio.
Toute nouveauté, toute approche nouvelle où on prend un risque, c'est un point froid. Et voilà, il faut le réchauffer pour que l'auditeur se l'apprivoise et s'y sente bien.
Sur ce type de radio, entre guillemets, de mémoire, on joue sur du velours, surtout en 2019, où l'époque est incertaine.
Tu n'avais pas d'expérience managériale à l'époque ? Tu n'étais-
Toi, tu as lu un vieil article du Soir écrit par Fernand Letist ?
J'ai tout lu.
D'accord.
Tu n'avais jamais dirigé à proprement parler une équipe, une chaîne. Tu t'es retrouvé à la tête d'un paquet de gens, tu as pris des responsabilités.
Après 12 ans-
Oui.
...puisque tu as quitté le navire fin 2015.
Douze ans à la tête de Pure FM. On n'est forcément plus tout à fait la même personne qu'au début.
Non, bien sûr.
Qu'est-ce qui a changé chez toi personnellement, avant, après, pendant ?
La fonction fait l'homme et donc c'est vrai qu'une expérience comme celle-là, on n'en sort pas totalement indemne.
Ça ne veut pas dire, ce qui est exactement la même chose, mais à l'envers, mais ce n'est pas contradictoire.
Ce qui ne veut pas dire que tu en sors cabossé, blessé, estropié, pas du tout. Tu en sors aussi grandi et je trouve que ça m'a été très très utile de me mettre dans la position de,
devoir chaque fois trouver des solutions à des problèmes et de faire appel à ce qui est pour moi, au final, la chose qui m'amuse le plus, à savoir de la créativité.
Je disais ça à l'époque au directeur financier de la RTBF qui n'est plus le même, qui est parti aujourd'hui, mais qui était donc le directeur de la gestion financière de la RTBF.
Et je lui disais : Punaise, quand j'ai appréhendé, tu vois, les premiers profils du job, une des choses qui me paraissait, pour moi, la plus compliquée, la plus,
embêtante, c'était la gestion financière.
Et je lui ai dit : Eh ben, je me suis dit qu'au bout du compte, trouver des solutions
dans un problème d'équation, de gestion financière, c'était aussi à un moment donné, faire appel à de la créativité pour se sortir de la problématique.
Comment retrouver de l'argent ? Comment faire pour qu'une chose existe en sachant que l'enveloppe, elle n'est pas ouverte et il faut faire avec ce qu'on a.
Donc, il faudrait peut-être ralentir ou arrêter quelque chose si on veut des nouveaux moyens pour entamer de nouvelles choses.
Et je dis : Ben, même ça, il y a une part de créativité qui me plaît dans l'approche de la gestion financière.
Alors qu'au départ, c'était peut-être quelque chose qui ne m'intéressait pas. Voilà, je me suis découvert deux ou trois affinités aussi avec les ressources humaines, qui est encore un autre volet compliqué dans le management.
Mais globalement, défendre des idées, entraîner une équipe avec soi, trouver les moyens d'ouvrir des chantiers et essayer de lancer de nouvelles choses.
Tu vois, sur une chaîne jeune comme Pure FM à l'époque, le job n'est jamais fini quoi, parce qu'on est forcément sur une chaîne qui est-
Qui se renouvelle, dont le public se renouvelle.
Mais oui, c'est même sa raison d'être, à savoir, on est en permanente réflexion sur c'est quoi le prochain coup à jouer, c'est quoi la prochaine-
Le positionnement.
...chose à côté de laquelle il ne faut pas passer, le prochain mouvement, etc. Et tout ça mis ensemble crée effectivement des mouvements dans le positionnement.
Donc, c'est un projet, entre guillemets, une chaîne jeune comme ça, qui n'est jamais fini. Le jour où il est fini, c'est que c'est devenu une chaîne comme Nostalgie.
C'est jamais fini. Voilà. Je dirais que presque chaque jour, il fallait remettre son titre en jeu. C'est ça qui était intéressant.
Ça me parle beaucoup ce que tu dis. Il y a un côté entrepreneurial, un côté-
Oui.
...prise de risque. Oui. On sait que Pure, ça n'a pas toujours été un animal facile à gérer.
Non.
Quand on lit les articles, la RTBF semblait presque toujours un peu déçue des audiences qui plafonnaient 2, 3 % alors qu'on disait à côté, Classic 21, on était plus dans les 8, 9 pour cent.
Oui.
Il y a eu des changements fondamentaux, donc, on disait-
Oui, oui.
...un renouvellement perpétuel, voilà, en termes de stratégie, de ligne éditoriale, de grille, d'animateurs. Quel regard est-ce que tu portes aujourd'hui sur l'aventure Pure FM en rétrospective, voilà, vis-à-vis de
ces difficultés que tu as pu avoir au niveau de l'audience ?
Tout le monde a des difficultés.
Oui.
Oui, on peut parler avec Marc Isaïx, que j'ai encore très très souvent au téléphone, qui est donc le patron de Classic-- enfin, qui était le patron-
Qui était. Il vient de prendre sa retraite, oui.
...de Classic 21. Voilà, il vient de prendre sa retraite. Ça n'a jamais été non plus une promenade ou aucune partie de plaisir.
Forcément, il y a toujours dans ce type d'aventure des choses qui sont un peu moins agréables, plus compliquées à gérer.
Par rapport à Pure, moi, je suis content parce que quand je suis parti, l'audience de la chaîne était à 3.6, 3.7.
Elle n'avait jamais été aussi haute, voilà, sans forcément faire une programmation triviale, racoleuse. Et donc, j'en suis sorti, je trouve, avec un beau bilan et un beau bulletin.
Pour le reste, oui, effectivement, y arriver était extrêmement compliqué. Quand tu compares avec une chaîne comme Studio Bruxelles, par exemple, voilà.
Oui. La comparaison revient souvent.
La comparaison revient souvent. Or, la comparaison est totalement impossible. Le paysage flamand n'est pas du tout le même-
C'est sûr.
...que le paysage francophone. D'abord, ce n'est pas le même bassin de population et en quantité et en, je dirais, en profil et culturellement, j'allais dire en qualité, mais c'est peut-être-
Ouh là, attention.
Ouais, attention. Mais ce n'est pas le même profil, ce n'est pas le, les-- oui, ce n'est pas le même profil de population.
Et puis surtout, la Flandre a eu, peut-être à tort, cette stratégie de ne pas ouvrir son paysage radiophonique à tous les intervenants venus de l'extérieur.
Ils sont restés quand même relativement monopolistiques. Il y a eu des initiatives comme Vire FM ou des choses comme ça, mais qui restaient quand même des projets flamands qui émergeaient depuis le territoire flamand.
On n'a pas vu tout à coup des grands réseaux hollandais, je cherche d'autres pays qui parlent-
Mais je crois qu'il y a NRJ qui est présent en Flandre maintenant.
Ouais, mais c'est NRJ. C'est tout petit, petit Nostalgie aussi. Voilà, ça représente pas grand-chose.
En fait, ça permet surtout à NRJ et à Nostalgie de proposer aux annonceurs une couverture nationale qui est beaucoup plus attrayante.
Qui penche la balance, ouais.
Bah oui, c'est ça. Quand on propose une campagne nationale à un annonceur, c'est toujours beaucoup mieux que de lui dire : « Nous, on peut te proposer une-
C'est ça.
Une campagne régionale Sud-- Bruxelles sud du pays. » Et-- mais par ailleurs, il y aura un autre interlocuteur pour te vendre la même chose pour le nord.
Mais pour en revenir sur le plan des fréquences, du côté wallon, c'était une vraie passoire. On a laissé rentrer Fun Radio, on a laissé rentrer NRJ Nostalgie, on a laissé rentrer Chérie FM, on a laissé rentrer des projets,
venant du groupe RTL qui-
Pas assez ouvert en Flandre, mais beaucoup trop ouvert côté Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles. C'est ça que tu dis ?
Bah à un moment donné, je veux dire, il y a un gâteau à se partager. Et ce gâteau, il n'est pas extensible à l'infini.
Il y a un certain nombre d'auditeurs potentiels. Ils ont chacun deux oreilles et pas quatre ou cinq oreilles. Et il faut se battre pour se partager ça.
Voilà. Avec parfois des gens qui travaillent avec d'autres moyens. Une marque comme NRJ profite énormément de leur promiscuité avec TF1.
Mais comme le public belge francophone peut regarder TF1, lorsqu'il voit NRJ, qui est une marque qui est vraiment omniprésente sur TF1, ça leur fait une vitrine promotionnelle, mais qui est colossale.
Et eux ne font pas la différence entre la marque NRJ française et les programmes NRJ Belgique quoi.
Mhm.
Voilà, donc on ne part pas exactement avec les mêmes armes. Et puis nous aussi, on est ici à la RTBF un service public. Ça veut dire qu'il y a un contrat de gè-
de gestion, il y a toute une série de choses,
qui sont importantes à conserver,
des choses qui sont aussi importantes à surveiller parce que, que ce soit en forme de quota ou--
voilà, il y a une déontologie, une manière de faire de la radio et puis aussi des chiffres à respecter parce qu'ils font partie de ce que l'on doit au gouvernement via le contrat de gestion puisqu'on vit
pour 70 % de la-
Oui, mais donc tu fais un listing assez complet, enfin assez long, j'allais dire, de difficultés, d'obstacles, voilà, qui sont face à la RTBF, à Pure FM, voilà, entre 2004 et 2016 et même encore aujourd'hui.
Quand on parle de cette période et qu'on parle de consommation musicale, on ne pense pas en premier lieu à la radio FM, on pense à l'émergence de Kazaa, eMule, Limewire, Blog Musik, Deezer, YouTube, Spotify.
Donc tu as des nouveaux modes de consommation,
un peu moins tout de même à la radio FM. Donc il y a eu tous ces changements importants en termes de consommation de musique, en particulier de la part du jeune public, puisqu'on pouvait tout à coup écouter-
La plupart de ce que tu m'as énoncé, que ce soit Kazaa, Limewire-
eMule.
eMule, tout ça n'existe plus.
Non, tout ça n'existe plus, mais sur cette période de temps, tout ça émergeait.
Ouais, mais ça concernait quand même un public de niche et de geek et pas le grand public-
Ça, c'est le premier que j'ai listé. Et puis-
Qui aime bien allumer sa radio et puis recevoir un-
Ça, ce sont les premiers que j'ai listés, mais après ça, on a vu émerger Blog Musik, Deezer, YouTube, Spotify.
Ça commence seulement aujourd'hui à se populariser, je dirais, de façon large. Netflix y a été pour beaucoup. Spotify qui essaye aujourd'hui, en se lançant dans le podcast, qui essaye de se positionner comme une sorte de Netflix audio.
Ils essayent de produire leur propre contenu.
Ouais, ils ont bien compris l'enjeu. C'est qu'en étant seulement un robinet à musique, ils vont pas y arriver.
Donc ils proposent autre chose. Oui, ou alors ils ont des exclusivités. Par exemple, Amazon, avec son programme Prime, permet aussi, je pense que ça s'appelle Amazon Music, tout simplement, leur
programme de streaming.
Ils ont des exclusivités. Par exemple, ils proposent des chansons que tu ne trouveras pas ailleurs.
Spotify fait ça aussi, hein, des sets acoustiques live.
Bah ici, c'est pas des mini concerts ou... C'est carrément des enregistrements qui sont-
C'est ça.
Exclusifs à Amazon Music quoi. Mais tu sais, quand Adèle a lancé son dernier album, qui s'appelait 23 ?
Certainement.
C'est ça le dernier ?
25, je ne sais plus.
Je sais pas. Il y avait 19, 21 et 23. Enfin, je crois que c'est 23, sur lequel il y avait Hello. Enfin-- donc cet album était hyper attendu et Apple Music lui a fait une offre qui était d'avoir l'album pendant, je crois-
25, le dernier.
25 ? OK.
Twenty-five.
Twenty-five. Donc, d'avoir l'album pendant un an en exclusivité sur Apple Music, sauf les singles. Ça, elle pouvait les distribuer en radio et ailleurs.
Ça servait un peu de locomotive pour l'ensemble de l'album. Et donc, en gros, en lui disant : « Tu ne permets pas de laisser la diffusion de tes chansons ailleurs que chez nous.
Et pour ça, on te donne un fi- » Je crois que c'était sur plusieurs années. Il y avait même une somme qui augmentait d'année en année.
C'était mais colossal. C'était lui garantir des millions et des millions d'albums. Enfin, ça correspondait la somme à autant de millions d'albums vendus sans devoir les vendre quoi.
Elle a refusé, mais un jour, on va y arriver. C'est que le nouveau Ed Sheeran ou le nouveau Coldplay, tu pourras pas l'entendre à la radio parce que
un acteur de streaming aura acheté les droits et si tu veux l'entendre, tu devras t'abonner à cette plateforme.
Ça va se diviser. Est-ce qu'à ce moment-là, on va pas retourner à se dire : bon ben, je suis obligé de le pirater du coup, puisque je suis déjà abonné à Spotify et que je veux un album exclu à Apple Music.
Est-ce qu'ils ne sont pas en train de se tirer un peu une balle dans le pied ?
Oui, mais ça, tu te places dans la position utilisateur où tu dis moi utilisateur, si ça se passe comme ça, je pirate.
Moi, mon discours, il est du côté de l'opérateur. Comment à un moment donné pourra-t-on vivre sans avoir la possibilité de diffuser les artistes les plus populaires sur le marché ?
Artistes dont la popularité a été gagnée d'ailleurs en passant par les réseaux traditionnels à un moment ou à un autre de leur carrière.
Ça va être extrêmement compliqué.
Yes. Mais donc il y a eu tout de même-- enfin, je reviens sur ce que je disais voilà entre 2004 et 2016 et même après, voilà, des évolutions très importantes au niveau de la consommation de musique.
Oui.
En 2009, moi, je pense que quand je voulais écouter une chanson, j'attendais pas qu'elle passe à la radio comme-
Bien sûr.
...comme vingt ans avant, mais je, voilà, je tapais le nom sur YouTube et j'écoutais instantanément.
Comment est-ce que ça impacte une radio FM pour les jeunes quand tout d'un coup, ben le public jeune, il peut écouter tout ce qu'il veut quand il veut et que
voilà ces options-là sont sans doute plus attirantes, plus attrayantes que le fait d'attendre à la radio que la chanson-
Bah oui.
...nouvelle chanson passe.
Alors, faut poser la question à ceux qui s'occupent des radios jeunes, c'est plus mon cas.
Oui, mais tu t'en es occupé dans cette période charnière.
Il y a deux,
deux attitudes à avoir. La première, c'est ne jamais oublier l'ancrage local, donc de vraiment parler aux gens de ce qui se passe autour de chez eux, d'avoir une proximité, ce que ne pourront jamais faire
tous les algorithmes du monde parce que,
on ne connaît bien que ce que,
que ce qui est proche et que l'auditeur sente qu'on s'adresse à lui, qu'on connaît son environnement et qu'il est resitué dans un ensemble.
Ça, c'est extrêmement important. On va avoir cet ancrage local. Et puis deuxièmement, c'est d'avoir autour de la musique un accompagnement que ces plateformes de streaming ne font pas toujours.
Alors les plus pointus, les plus grands amateurs de musique, ou les plus curieux n'auront jamais besoin d'un accompagnement.
Mais je dirais que pour une fraction de la population qui n'est pas marginale, ils aiment bien que le travail soit prémâché et que donc une radio fasse ce rôle éditorial de faire le tri avant d'en arriver à la diffusion.
Moi, je compare toujours ça à une sorte de pâtisserie où on lance des gens dans le magasin en disant : voilà, c'est open bar, vous mangez tout ce que vous voulez, c'est un peu ça Spotify,
vous pouvez y aller, c'est compris dans le prix et c'est open.
Ben ce qui va se passer, c'est que tout le monde va mordre un peu dans tout pour goûter jusqu'à s'en rendre malade et vomir, mais ils n'auront réellement goûté ni profité de rien.
Je discutais à l'époque avec le responsable de Deezer en Belgique. Le bureau n'existe plus. Le bureau belge a fermé.
Il me disait que dans leurs statistiques, eux pouvaient voir le temps qu'une chanson était écoutée avant d'être abandonnée par celui qui a fait play quoi.
En gros, est-ce que les gens qui écoutent écoutent en entier ? Non. C'est incroyable le nombre de chansons qui ne sont même pas écoutées plus d'une minute.
Et puis on passe à autre chose. Une espèce de frénésie comme ça, du zapping. Comme je disais, on mord dans l'éclair au chocolat, on jette le reste et puis on se jette sur une tarte aux fraises et puis on jette et puis ouais, ah merveilleux !
Et on mord une-- oui, et au bout d'un moment, more is less quoi. La surabondance, avoir trop de choix, empêche de choisir ou en tout cas de faire des choix pertinents.
Donc il y aura toujours besoin d'une approche éditoriale ou d'une curation pour ceux qui sont un peu perdus quand on les laisse à la manœuvre
de quelque chose dans lequel ils n'ont pas toujours tous les outils pour s'y retrouver.
Yes. Mais la découverte du terreau musical un peu plus local, ça présume tout de même, voilà, une certaine curiosité-
Bien sûr
...pour ce qui est neuf. Et dans une chronique que tu faisais en juin dernier, tu expliquais justement que deux personnes sur trois étaient bloquées dans un style musical bien particulier-
Exact
...qu'on reste cloisonné, coincé dans ce qu'on connaît déjà. Donc finalement, on a un public qui peut écouter ce qu'il veut quand il veut, qui n'a pas envie de découvrir des trucs nouveaux.
On sait aussi que voilà la RTBF, à cause de la-- c'est très technique, mais la libéralisation des ondes FM, voilà, s'est attaquée peut-être au public jeune un peu plus tard qu'à l'étranger.
Donc on a tous ces challenges-là au niveau du public-
Ouais
...au niveau des modes de diffusion, au niveau des contraintes que t'as listées avant, la concurrence et tout ça. Quand on dit tout ça, mais enfin, question un peu provoque, mais on se dit : mais est-ce que c'est pas un peu perdu d'avance ? Est-ce que-
Non, perdu d'avance non-
Est-ce qu'on ne nage pas à contre-courant ?
Non, perdu d'avance non. Par contre, il faut rester très, très lucide et très, très humble sur les objectifs qui sont potentiellement possibles.
En gros, avec une chaîne musicale jeune basée sur la découverte, sur le développement d'artistes émergents, sur l'accompagnement,
viser dix points de parts de marché en Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles, compte tenu du bassin de population et compte tenu de l'approche du profil éditorial de la radio à développer, c'est absolument impossible.
C'est totalement impossible.
Par contre, avoir un objectif qui est raisonnable, qui est effectivement quelque chose autour de quatre, quatre et demi, et j'te dis, moi, j'ai laissé, j'en suis assez fier, la radio à trois point sept,
ça reste quand même dans l'ordre du possible.
Et ce possible, quand tu es une radio qui, quelque part, comme on appelle ça, fait de la prescription, c'est-à-dire qu'on est early adopteur.
Donc en gros, on est les premiers à proposer quelque chose avec toujours l'espoir que d'autres radios plus populaires vont s'en emparer pour porter des artistes ou des chansons plus loin.
Là où toi, ton domaine s'arrête.
Ça, c'est la particularité du service public, ça.
Mais oui, on m'a toujours dit : « Ouais, tu te rends compte, vous avez été les premiers à passer, je sais pas, que ce soit Girls in Hawaii ou Alison Deroo ou Soldout. »
Noa Moon.
Noa Moon, voilà. Eh beh, c'est un bon exemple, des gens comme ça.
Mmm-mmh.
Ils m'ont dit : « Et maintenant, Radio Contact ou NRJ les passe. » Et moi, je réponds : « Mais c'est super ».
Oui, tant mieux.
Ben ouais, tant mieux. Tant mieux pour eux, tant mieux pour elle. Ça-
C'est bizarre parce que les artistes vous appartiennent pas. Enfin, c'est quoi le-
Mais non, les artistes-- mais non, mais c'est toujours le côté : « Ouais, vous vous êtes fait racketter, c'est vous qui les avez développés-
Ouais, prise de risque qui ne paye pas tellement quoi, ouais.
Mais ça, je dirais que pour moi, la plus belle des récompenses, c'est que quand un artiste parti de rien est développé sur une antenne dont j'avais la responsabilité, finit par passer sur des radios populaires, commerciales,
beaucoup beaucoup plus généralistes en termes musical, ça veut dire qu'on avait misé sur les bons chevaux.
Et surtout, ben c'est comme quand tu donnes la main à un enfant pour lui apprendre à marcher, à un moment donné, tu lui lâches la main, tu te dis : « Vas-y ».
Et ça, c'est une vraie,
une vraie fierté quoi, une vraie satisfaction. Sachant que, ben une fois que celui-là vit sa vie, on va voir à qui on peut maintenant accorder de l'attention pour faire le même travail, puisque c'est un travail sans fin.
Pour parler un petit peu de Pure après ton départ, moi, quand--
pendant mon adolescence, quand j'écoutais Pure, c'était, voilà, les émissions préférées, c'était
Snooze le matin en me lavant les dents et puis Cinq Heures Cinéma le mercredi après-midi et puis de temps en temps des trucs le week-end.
Il me semble qu'aujourd'hui, la chaîne ne veut pas vraiment faire émerger de personnalités, hein. C'est beaucoup de pigistes parmi les animateurs.
Ils ont pas de CDI, ils peuvent se faire éjecter assez facilement. C'est quoi la logique derrière ça exactement, de-
Je sais pas, je suis pas là-
Tu n'es pas, OK.
Je suis pas derrière ça.
C'est ça.
Et je ne connais pas le statut. Tu me parles de pigistes, de CDI, j'en sais rien.
C'est ça, OK.
Je connais pas le cadastre de-
OK, pas de souci, ouais.
Ni de Pure ni de-
OK, j'évacue la question alors.
Ni des autres chaînes. Je-
Ah.
Mais il faut aller poser la question à ceux qui s'occupent de ça.
Oui, oui, tout à fait.
Tu sais, moi, ça fait bientôt trois ans que je n'y suis plus.
Ouais.
Donc j'imagine que des choses ont changé. Et dans quel sens ? Je n'y ai aucun-
Je vais peut-être poser la question autrement.
Juste avant ton départ, tu avais validé un projet d'une petite émission qui s'appelait Radar avec un monsieur qui s'appelle Maxime Wattieu et deux madames qui s'appelaient Sarah Baum et Fanny Ruwet,
qu'on embrasse très fort.
Et ce projet, voilà, a disparu après un an. Donc c'est un petit peu ce que je vois comme quelque chose d'emblématique-
Ben il faut-
Au changement de direction de la chaîne.
Ben il faut aller poser la question à ceux qui ont pris la décision à ce moment.
La question que je vais te poser, c'est : oui, comment est-ce que toi, tu le vois quand tu fais émerger un projet qui disparaît juste après ?
Alors moi, je suis dans un état d'esprit où quand je m'occupe de quelque chose, je m'en occupe à cent pour cent.
Mmm. Quand tu t'en occupes plus.
Quand je m'en occupe plus, je m'en occupe plus.
Ouais.
Voilà. Ou sinon, tu finis par re-- et tu sais, dans ma vie, j'ai maintenant cinquante-huit ans, je me suis occupé de beaucoup de choses.
Donc si je dois revenir en arrière sur toutes les choses dont je me suis occupé et en disant : « Oui, mais si ce-- avec des oui, mais non, mais si » et pfff, voilà, je m'en occupe, je m'en occupe, je m'en occupe pas, je m'en occupe pas.
Ce genre de questions, il faut interpeller ceux qui ont pris les-
Ceux qui ont la responsabilité.
Les décisions.
Je comprends.
Moi, je peux te parler de l'intérêt d'une émission comme celle-là, puisque je l'ai mise en place. Maintenant, de l'intérêt de l'arrêter, comme ce n'est pas ma décision, ce n'est pas à moi à la commenter.
Tu évoquais tout à l'heure la question du budget. Est-ce que Pure a ou avait, dans ta période, oui, les moyens d'aller à la hauteur de ses ambitions ?
Bien sûr, bien sûr. Que ça soit sur des sorties en festival, que ça soit sur des sessions acoustiques, des showcases, que ça soit sur des émissions à mettre en place, que ça soit sur une grille de programmes
spéciale pour les fêtes de fin d'année, pour l'été, que ça soit sur, même sur le merchandising, des goodies, des choses comme ça ou des campagnes de pub, ouais.
Mais à un moment donné, quand on parle d'argent, il y a aussi des choix à faire, hein. Mais je pense que par rapport aux choses que je voulais faire, j'ai toujours trouvé les moyens de les-
Oui. L'approche créative que tu évoquais tout à l'heure.
Ouais, de les réaliser.
Mmm.
En laissant parfois tomber d'autres choses.
Très bien. Aujourd'hui, quand tu es chroniqueur chez Medical Fact-
Oui.
Le matin dans Matin Première.
Le sujet que tu évoques le plus souvent-
Oui.
Ta spécialité, c'est, voilà, plutôt l'industrie musicale, les tendances, le streaming, les concerts, les deals avec les majors.
On l'a dit, la consommation musicale aujourd'hui n'a rien à voir avec ce que c'était il y a vingt ans. Le piratage est passé par là, le streaming est passé par là.
Quand on écoute certains, on a l'impression que c'est beaucoup plus dur pour les artistes aujourd'hui, que rien ne va plus, que le public n'est plus prêt à dépenser de l'argent pour sa musique, que le streaming n'apporte plus rien.
Dans Recommandé par Cinq Heures, j'ai pu lire à un moment donné : « L'industrie est fauchée. » Et pourtant-
Oui.
Chaque année, quand on voit les rentrées d'argent des majors, on voit que ça bat des records, c'est de plus en plus élevé. Et que l'industrie semble, en tout cas de l'extérieur, se portait plutôt bien financièrement.
Alors, il faut recontextualiser. Nous avons dit, j'ai dit, on l'a écrit dans un bouquin : il y a deux ans, l'industrie est fauchée.
Depuis 2016, oui 2016, parce que là, on est au tout début 2019. Depuis 2016, depuis deux ans et quelques mois, l'industrie de la musique va bien, très bien.
Elle n'a jamais été aussi bien aujourd'hui que depuis ces heures superbes des années 60, 70, 80.
Donc il y a vraiment eu un passage à vide ?
Oui, il y a eu un passage à vide parce qu'il y a eu à un moment donné le CD qui ne se vendait plus et le streaming n'était pas encore complètement adopté, du moins pour sa partie payante.
Donc, il y a eu une sorte de in between, un gap, un peu une zone qui était en friche, voilà, une traversée du désert.
Aujourd'hui, ça va super bien. Mais le problème, c'est que c'est beaucoup, beaucoup, beaucoup, beaucoup d'argent. Plus qu'ils n'en ont jamais eu, mais il est partagé par un nombre de personnes réduit. C'est-à-dire que
sur l'ensemble des millions de dollars qui sont générés, l'assiette est partagée. Je pense que je l'avais expliqué d'ailleurs dans cette explication, enfin dans ce billet, ça, c'est bien aussi.
Enfin, j'avais aussi désigné qui étaient les grands vainqueurs quoi. C'est en réalité trois labels qui se-- enfin trois maisons de disques, trois entreprises qui se partagent le gâteau.
Mais dans ces entreprises, c'est quatre ou cinq têtes qui raflent la toute grande majorité de l'argent disponible. Donc, ce qui reste pour les autres, ben effectivement, c'est pas grand-chose.
Donc ça, c'est strictement une question-
Mais l'industrie, elle, elle est en bonne santé. Les gens qui reçoivent l'argent sont des gens qui sont réellement écoutés, mais pour,
dix ou quinze artistes écoutés et qui monopolisent à peu près toute l'écoute mondiale, derrière, il y a des centaines et des centaines d'artistes qui, eux, doivent vivre avec un peu les miettes.
Le problème, il est là, c'est qu'on a des artistes blockbusters qui monopolisent à peu près tout, toute l'écoute, tout le streaming mondial.
Et c'est un petit groupe quoi, ils sont pas nombreux.
Quand tu dis que tous les autres doivent survivre avec des miettes, est-ce que c'est relatif ? Et que c'est juste que Kanye West fait des milliards et que les autres se font seulement cinquante mille euros par an ?
Ou bien, enfin, quel est l'ordre d'idée exactement ?
Je crois que par rapport aux premiers qui se font des centaines de millions d'euros, ceux qui sont déjà dans la catégorie en dessous, on parle plutôt en dizaines de milliers.
Je pense qu'il y a un-- Mais c'est comme le monde socioéconomique dans lequel on vit aujourd'hui, la middle class, entre guillemets-
Loin, loin derrière le top
...a plutôt tendance à disparaître. Et on a soit les classes vraiment triple A supérieures et puis très vite en dessous, on retombe sur des classes
inférieures qui gagnent beaucoup moins, mais entre les deux, il n'y a plus beaucoup de place quoi.
J'écoutais il y a quelques mois une interview de Charlie Manson chez Joe Rogan. Elle parlait des deals trois cent soixante.
Quoi aujourd'hui, quand on signe chez Universal, ils prennent sur tout.
Oui.
C'est-- Tu peux nous expliquer un peu cette tendance ? D'où ça vient ?
Ben en fait, la tendance vient-- Ben il faut remonter aux origines. Quand un artiste signe un contrat avec une maison de disque, il signe pour que la maison de disque ait les droits d'exploitation de ses chansons
dans le format enregistré qui sera livré pour-- à exploiter.
Mais donc du coup, la maison de disque paie pour que l'artiste ait les moyens de réaliser ses enregistrements. Donc du coup, l'artiste garde ses droits d'auteur.
La maison de disque a ce qu'on appelle le droit sur le master, c'est-à-dire l'exploitation de l'enregistrement des chansons dans le format original qui est celui qu'on va sortir, qu'on va livrer aux radios et mettre en magasin.
C'est tout. L'artiste fait des concerts, ce n'est pas le problème de la maison de disque. La chanson est adaptée dans une autre langue, ce n'est pas le problème de la maison de disque, c'est le problème de l'éditeur.
La chanson est utilisée pour une publicité. Ben la maison de disque peut demander un peu de sous parce que si c'est la version de l'album, la version dont eux ont payé l'enregistrement qui est utilisée, ils peuvent avoir un petit retour là-dessus.
Mais si on réenregistre la chanson pour la placer dans une pub, parce qu'on trouve que le format sera plus adapté en la réenregistrant, la maison de disque ne gagne pas d'argent là-dessus. Donc quelque part,
à la grande époque où on vend du disque, tout ça n'est pas très contraignant. La maison de disque s'en sort largement avec uniquement les ventes de disques et l'exploitation du matériel sonore sur un support physique,
que ça soit des cassettes, des vinyles, puis plus tard le CD.
Et puis avec le piratage, avec le téléchargement, la disparition, la crise du disque.
Dès le moment où le disque ne se vend plus
Ce n'est pas seulement l'artiste qui perd de l'argent, mais aussi la maison de disques qui décide quelque part
d'augmenter son secteur d'activité et de se diversifier pour être à peu près à tous les postes où un artiste peut gagner de l'argent.
Ça veut dire qu'on a aujourd'hui des maisons de disques qui continuent à faire leur job de maison de disques, mais lorsque tu signes un contrat, tu dois céder par exemple tes droits éditoriaux en tout ou en partie.
Donc c'est l'exploitation de tes droits d'auteur. Tu dois peut-être aussi signer avec la branche organisateur de concerts de la maison de disques.
Chaque maison de disques a une branche concert pour les tournées. Donc
signer aussi avec cette branche-là pour que chaque fois que l'artiste monte sur scène, ben la maison de disques qui n'est plus juste qu'une maison de disques, qui est plutôt une plateforme de, de, de, de
promotion, de production, de diffusion et d'exploitation du matériel d'un artiste puisse aussi toucher sur ça.
La maison de disques peut aussi vouloir un pourcentage sur la vente des t-shirts. Ils peuvent aussi vouloir avoir un pourcentage sur l'exploitation, par exemple, d'un site internet.
On sait que beaucoup d'artistes, et parmi les plus grands comme U2, ils ont des sites qui sont payants. D'ailleurs, tu dois t'inscrire pour pouvoir être le premier à pouvoir acheter des tickets et toujours avoir les bons tickets.
Mais il faut y... voilà. Beaucoup d'artistes ont des sites qui sont payants. La maison de disques veut aussi son droit de retour payant sur l'image de l'artiste, sur les vidéos de l'artiste.
Donc il y a vraiment l'idée d'investir dans un artiste, l'aider à démarrer et puis on récupère tout ce qui pousse après.
Dès le départ, contractuellement, l'artiste est lié à la maison de disques pour toutes ces formes d'activités qui peuvent rapporter de l'argent.
C'était pas du tout le cas avant. Tu avais des interlocuteurs différents pour chacune de tes activités.
Donc il y a vraiment l'idée de non plus simplement presser des disques, mais s'occuper de la distribution, s'occuper du marketing, s'occuper de la présence médiatique.
On ne presse plus des disques.
Oui, c'est ça.
Ça n'existe plus. Voilà.
Presque plus, oui.
Presque plus, oui. Il y a un petit marché pour le vinyle qui est balbutiant, mais c'est, voilà, c'est, c'est comme...
C'est un exotique, oui.
Ben c'est comme les gens qui mangent bio quoi. Voilà. Ben oui, oui, oui. C'est comme le retour de la cassette, ça me fait rire.
C'est ce côté un petit peu vintage, marrant.
Oui, c'est sûr, oui.
On rachète une platine et on écoute un vinyle.
Je me souviens qu'en 2012, quand je regardais tout ça, on fantasmait un petit peu en se disant : Ben aujourd'hui, finalement, la distribution, on n'a plus besoin de presser des disques, on n'a plus besoin de la maison de disques.
On enregistre en studio sa musique, on la distribue sur Internet. Et puis les ventes de tickets de concerts vont faire fois cinq.
Tout le monde va arriver dans les salles de concert parce qu'ils ont piraté le disque, qu'ils connaissent les bonnes chansons.
Finalement, ça s'est pas passé comme ça puisque l'industrie du disque, d'après ce que tu me dis...
Oui.
Un petit peu serrer les dents un petit peu...
Mais je pense que ça fait plusieurs fois que tu utilises le mot pirate, piratage, pirater. Je crois que cette époque-là du téléchargement...
Je parle du passé.
Ou du piratage. Oui, oui. C'est une époque qui est déjà révolue.
Bien sûr.
Et depuis que les services de streaming restent à des prix abordables. Et, encore une fois, je pense que Netflix y a été pour beaucoup, à savoir offrir un catalogue absolument incroyable pour neuf euros nonante-neuf par mois.
C'est le même tarif qui est pratiqué par Spotify, par Apple Music. Avoir accès à une sorte de bibliothèque mondiale de façon immédiate, permanente, sans limite pour dix euros par mois,
avec un confort d'écoute qui n'est pas
perturbé par des instabilités de connexion ou bien simplement interrompu par de la pub.
Mais les observateurs l'avaient toujours dit : le jour où le business offrira à un prix raisonnable un service de qualité, les gens vont payer.
C'est que pendant des années, l'industrie du disque s'est protégée de ses consommateurs en mettant des...
Des DRM.
Des DRM, voilà, en watermarkant les trucs. On se souvient même d'une époque où les gens achetaient un
CD et ils ne savaient pas les écouter dans les voitures Mercedes parce que les lecteurs embarqués dans les Mercedes refusaient de lire un disque qui était protégé, enfin un CD qui était protégé par un DRM.
Mais je ne sais pas si on se rend compte dans quel monde, à un moment donné, le consommateur, l'amateur de musique a été obligé de vivre pour avoir accès à ses artistes préférés.
Je ne connais aucun autre exemple dans le monde où une industrie se protège de ses consommateurs. C'est complètement dingue.
C'était complètement dingue. Au lieu d'essayer d'écouter les besoins et d'apporter des solutions. Donc là, il y a eu un moment donné où
il y a eu une espèce de cacophonie comme ça entre ce qu'il fallait proposer, comment faire pour ne pas le donner, mais le vendre.
Enfin voilà, c'était un moment très très très compliqué
et sans issue. Là aujourd'hui, avec la manière d'envisager le streaming tel qu'il est là et avec évidemment toutes les précautions que j'ai expliquées, c'est beaucoup les mêmes qui se taillent la part du gâteau.
Il ne reste pas beaucoup pour les autres, mais au moins pour un prix abordable, on a accès à un service qui est de qualité et qui est illimité.
C'est ce que les gens voulaient, c'est ce que les gens avaient toujours dit. Le jour où on nous donnera pour un prix raisonnable quelque chose de qualité, bien sûr qu'on va payer.
On ne va pas s'embêter à télécharger illégalement. Et résultat, voilà ce qui avait été annoncé s'est produit.
Durant justement cette période de transition un petit peu difficile, cette traversée du désert, certains se disaient : Ben finalement, pourquoi est-ce que les artistes ne peuvent pas aller juste en studio ?
Enregistrer leurs trucs avec leurs producteurs. Voilà, ils travaillent sur leur disque, ils prennent leur temps.
Puis une fois que c'est fait, bah ils vont directement chez Spotify, ils vont directement, voilà, sur les plateformes, qu'elles soient légales, qu'elles soient illégales, peu importe.
Mais bon aujourd'hui, on est plutôt évidemment... puisque le streaming est roi. Mais pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'est pas juste passés
à un modèle de consommation où il y avait d'un côté le producteur de contenu, l'artiste, de l'autre côté l'auditeur et peut-être entre les deux, voilà...
Pas d'intermédiaires.
La salle de concert éventuellement quoi, voilà.
Oui, mais ça, c'est le grand fantasme de la blockchain, voilà qui... Mais...
Ouais.
C'est-à-dire qu'entre les deux, il y a quand même un passage qui est la promotion et la consolidation d'un nom qu'il faut...
C'est ça.
Faire grandir et répercuter et faire résonner. Voilà...
Oui, mais donc les majors sont vraiment devenus des boîtes de marketing quoi.
Bien sûr.
Ouais.
Évidemment. Les années 60, 70 et 80, les patrons des maisons de disques, ce sont d'abord des gens qui ont une fibre artistique et ils vont découvrir des talents, ils y croient et ils misent.
Depuis les années 90, les patrons des maisons de disques, ce sont des gens qui viennent de chez Danone, qui viennent de chez...
J'allais dire ils vendent des yaourts, ouais.
Bah ouais, qui viennent de chez IKEA, qui viennent de... tu sais, à un moment donné chez, je pense qu'il était chez EMI.
Ouais, chez EMI qui aujourd'hui n'existe plus puisque c'est Warner qui a racheté EMI. Les gars qui ont dû décider au moment du rachat quels artistes on garde, quels artistes on jette.
Ils avaient un tableau Excel et avec juste des chiffres. Mais...
Et je sais qu'un gars comme Alain Chamfort s'est retrouvé sur le carreau parce qu'en fait les chiffres en face du numéro de référence de ce qu'il représentait, mais son nom n'apparaissait même pas, c'était pas bon.
On jette. Qui est derrière Alain Chamfort ? On s'en fout. Oui, mais attends, Alain Chamfort, c'est quand même du patrimoine.
C'est quelqu'un qui à un moment donné, comme je dis toujours, qui a vendu vendra, on ne sait jamais. Il peut écrire pour d'autres.
Regarde, il l'a fait pour À cause des garçons. Les filles ont eu un tube
colossal. C'est quand même quelqu'un à manipuler avec précaution de par son trajet, sa carrière, un talent qui a quand même traversé plusieurs époques, même s'il vend moins aujourd'hui parce que c'est une personne, voilà, plus âgée.
Mais non, c'est considéré exactement sans précaution et c'est dégagé.
Il n'y a pas de capital de respect, capital de...
Non.
Voilà, non. On fait table rase de tout ça.
Et le problème aussi, c'est que, je le dis toujours, aujourd'hui, un artiste, pour être signé, doit déjà être connu.
Si tu prends une fille comme Lily Allen, elle avait déjà un potentiel et un following sur les réseaux avant même qu'une maison de disques ne veuille la signer.
Ed Sheeran, il était déjà assez grand sur YouTube et sur SoundCloud avant que Warner ne s'y intéresse et ne lui propose un contrat.
Aujourd'hui, on ne s'intéresse à toi que si tu as déjà fait toi-même tout seul une grande part du chemin. Tu dois déjà être professionnel avant qu'on te propose un contrat pro quoi.
Ou alors t'as des gens, voilà, à qui tout sourit comme Angèle qui a effectivement fait le boulot toute seule et a grandi, grandi, grandi sur les réseaux.
Et puis à un moment donné vient la question du contrat avec une maison de disques et à force de réfléchir, elle se dit : « Ben non,
je vais créer mon label et je vais simplement signer un deal de distribution et comme ça je reste entièrement
libre et indépendante ».
Et c'est ce qu'elle a fait. Et elle a bien fait.
Quand on se base sur toutes ces observations, toutes ces tendances, qu'on regarde le futur de l'industrie, est-ce qu'on,
est-ce qu'on maintient le cap vers, voilà, le deal 360, la prise de contrôle totale de ces majors par rapport à tous ces artistes...
Écoute Guillaume...
Il ne reste que des miettes ?
Si quelqu'un te dit : « Dans cinq ans, il va se passer ça et ça sera comme ça », c'est un menteur. Aujourd'hui, ce type d'environnement, c'est un peu comme la météo.
Tu peux faire des prévisions à cinq jours ou à dix jours, mais dire que la météo sera soit pluvieuse, enneigée ou ensoleillée dans six mois, c'est un leurre.
L'important, c'est de pouvoir continuer à avoir l'esprit assez ouvert que pour être prêt à tout. Comme dit le vieux singe tibétain : on va laisser les fenêtres ouvertes parce que le vent va souffler.
Alors d'où il va souffler ? On ne sait pas, mais ce qui est sûr, c'est qu'il va souffler. Voilà.
Yes.
Donc voilà, il faut vraiment être prêt à tout. Être prêt même à une chose et à son contraire. On est dans un milieu, dans un environnement qui est tellement mouvant et avec une rapidité
supersonique que prévoir qu'une chose va en entraîner une autre et que le résultat, ça sera ça
à trois ans, cinq ans, c'était impossible de le prévoir.
Ce qui est en train de se passer aujourd'hui, il y a deux ans, la preuve, je t'ai dit, tu me faisais la remarque très justement tout à l'heure en disant : oui, en 2016, tu disais que...
Exact, mais c'était le constat en 2016. J'aurais été incapable de te dire que deux ans et demi plus tard, la situation allait se renverser.
Oui, oui.
Par rapport à la rentabilité du streaming.
J'ai envie de faire une transition donc voilà sur toute cette discussion sur l'industrie de la musique, les tendances, traversée du désert et tout ça.
Quand on écoute Cinq Heures Cinéma et qu'on écoute les productions musicales de la France.
Oui.
Trois lettres qui reviennent souvent : GNQ.
Le grand n'importe quoi.
Ouais oui, oui, pardon. Oui, c'est très private joke là pour le coup.
Oui, c'est dans la mythologie.
C'est ça. Ce grand n'importe quoi de la grande majorité des productions musicales françaises.
Oui.
Comment est-ce que ça s'explique en fait ?
Ben la France a toujours été un peu une bulle, un territoire à part. D'abord, la France, c'est un pays de, je crois maintenant soixante-huit millions ou septante millions d'habitants.
Ouais, dans ces eaux-là.
Ouais. Nous, ici, on est quatre millions trois cent mille francophones en Belgique. Ça te situe déjà l'échelle.
Au niveau de la production musicale, au niveau du...
Au niveau de la production, mais aussi du potentiel du marché que cela représente.
Puisque chez nous, c'est très divisé, tout ça, voilà, ouais.
Ce qu'on sait peu, par exemple, c'est que la France est le deuxième marché du rap au monde après les États-Unis. Ce phénomène rap n'existe pas en Italie.
Ça existe en Italie, mais pas à hauteur de ce que la France produit. Ça existe en Allemagne, mais pas avec le potentiel que la France peut avoir sur ce marché-là.
Donc la France a toujours été dans une espèce de bulle comme ça, à part, qui se laissait très peu pénétrer par la musique venant de l'étranger.
Si tu regardes les années soixante et septante, tous les tubes de Johnny, de Sheila, de Sylvie Vartan, de Hugues Aufray, tous ces gens-là, c'était des traductions de chansons.
Oui, parce que les originaux en anglais n'arrivaient pas en France. D'abord parce que les gens ne comprenaient pas et le Français ne supporte pas de ne pas comprendre.
Et ça a mis un temps mais incroyable avant que les originaux pénètrent sur le territoire français
dans un premier temps, qu'on en parle dans les journaux français dans un deuxième temps et que ça soit diffusé sur les radios françaises dans un troisième temps.
Ils ont toujours ce problème aujourd'hui de quotas qui sont très très lourds, beaucoup plus lourds que chez nous,
où si une chanson doit être diffusée à la radio, il faut qu'une fraction de la chanson, un certain pourcentage, soit exprimée en français.
C'est pour ça, par exemple, on parlait de Noah Moon tout à l'heure. Son Paradise, il est sorti en France dans une version différente.
Il y avait une partie en duo en français avec je ne sais plus qui. C'est pour ça qu'une Lily Allen, à un moment donné, a fait un duo avec le fils de Souchon...
Ours.
...avec Ours. Voilà. Et que Mylène Farmer fait des chansons, a avec...
Dans les deux langues, ouais.
Ouais, mais elle a embarqué, à un moment donné, on l'a oublié, mais Moby est venu chanter avec elle. Maintenant, elle est avec Elpi.
Ce sont des portes d'entrée pour tous ces artistes anglo-saxons sur le territoire français, parce que c'est un territoire qui est très fermé, très très protectionniste.
Et l'origine de la question, c'était quoi ?
Comment est-ce que tu expliques le GNQ ? Quand je parle de GNQ, je pense par exemple les artistes prêtres, les...
Oui, oui, voilà.
Les pêcheurs, tout ça.
Voilà. Et donc, je veux dire, en vivant comme ça en vase clos, d'abord, c'est un peu comme les tribus qui vivent isolées en montagne.
Il y a un problème congénital, je pense, dans la musique en France. Ils doivent se reproduire entre eux, ils se font des feats les uns les autres.
Enfin... Et puis surtout, les fils de, les filles de. Ça, c'est vraiment un sport français aussi de premier plan, un manque de vision et aussi une sorte de, voilà, de repli sur soi qui n'a l'air de gêner personne.
Et cette espèce de... enfin, les prêtres, par exemple, comme M. Pokora qui reprend le catalogue de Claude François.
Ce sont tous des produits TF1 quoi. Il y a aussi
des, voilà, des relations un peu incestueuses. J'apprenais récemment que Zaz, par exemple, sous son côté chanteuse des rues, est quand même chez Une musique, ça veut dire un produit TF1.
Donc de là à ce qu'on la retrouve comme actrice dans une série TF1, comme ça a été le cas pour Jenifer, qui était une artiste TF1.
Pour Lorie en son temps et que tu retrouves alors ces gens à la manœuvre. C'est un petit peu ce qu'on expliquait avec le fameux trois cent soixante.
Là, on pousse le truc encore plus loin. Ce sont des poulains qui sont dans une écurie, qui est un opérateur audiovisuel.
On lui fait enregistrer des disques, on fait des émissions de variétés spéciales autour de l'artiste qui va finir par être la tête d'affiche d'une
série et faire acteur dans une série produite par le même opérateur audiovisuel.
Et comme ça, ça reste...
Quand tu parles de ces acteurs-là, audiovisuels, les groupes de télé TF1, NRJ, on sait justement que les jeunes consomment de moins en moins ces médias-là.
Oui.
Même si voilà, on peut penser à Quotidien qui fonctionne très bien avec les jeunes. Il y a des exceptions, mais en général, on se tourne plutôt vers Netflix, vers Spotify, vers Internet.
Bon alors, je sais que tu vas me dire qu'on ne peut pas prédire l'avenir, mais est-ce qu'on pourrait imaginer une érosion de ce côté consanguin des Français et peut-être une ouverture vers le monde grâce à ces acteurs Spotify ?
Tant TF1, ils ne sont pas complètement idiots. Si je ne m'abuse, ils ont quand même passé un contrat avec Norman, avec Cyprien, avec toute une série de youtubeurs.
Pour en faire quoi ? J'en sais trop rien. Ils ont eu finalement une émission en access prime sur TF1, un truc d'humour.
C'est pas à moi qu'il faut demander.
OK, mais ils avaient signé un contrat avec ces gens, donc ils sont quand même attentifs à ce qui se passe à l'extérieur.
Pas tant dans la démarche artistique de ces youtubeurs ou dans la qualité de leur écriture ou de leur interprétation,
mais ils voient simplement qu'ils font du clic et se disent : mais ce clic, il doit venir chez nous parce que ce clic, c'est le bruit de la caisse enregistreuse, ça va représenter de l'argent.
Donc voilà, maintenant, tu sais c'est—
Non, mais je dis, enfin, on sait quand on regarde les enquêtes qu'il y a plus, je crois qu'un jeune adulte sur trois qui regarde la télévision.
Donc forcément, TF1 essaye un petit peu de rattraper de ça, mais la tendance est là.
Oui, la tendance est là, mais de toute façon, ce qui intéresse TF1, ce sont des gens qui ont du pouvoir d'achat. Donc le jeune fauché qui fait du stop, voilà, ça les intéresse pas.
Donc ils vont aller plutôt s'adresser à ceux qui ont des revenus—
La ménagère, ouais
...des doubles revenus, la ménagère, comme on disait en son temps. Donc des gens qui ont du pouvoir d'achat et qui sont les décideurs de l'acte d'achat.
Sur base de ce constat, est-ce qu'on n'est pas amené à se dire : ce jeune public, peut-être, qui n'a plus envie de consommer TF1, qui n'intéresse pas TF1—
Oui
Et qui est sans doute beaucoup plus sur YouTube, sur Spotify. Est-ce que ce jeune public-là ne va pas quitter cette logique franco-française consanguine, comme on dit—
Ils l'ont déjà quittée.
Oui ? Donc c'est en train de se faire.
Oui, ils l'ont déjà quittée, effectivement. Mais voilà, de nouveau, une partie des jeunes, enfin, l'entièreté des jeunes est condamnée à devenir vieux.
Et ça, c'est un truc, c'est scientifique, c'est éprouvé scientifiquement.
J'ai entendu ça.
Voilà. Mais une partie de ces jeunes-là se complaisent et se contentent de ce qu'on va leur donner. Ceux dont tu parles, qui vont voir ailleurs, ça reste quand même une— ce n'est pas la grande majorité.
Ce n'est pas forcément la majorité la plus représentative des jeunes en France.
Revenons un petit peu donc sur Cinq Heures Cinéma, cette délicieuse émission que j'écoute depuis dix ans.
Pourquoi ? Avant, tu n'étais pas né ou tu étais juste sourd ?
2010, j'avais quel âge ? J'avais 16 ans. J'étais trop jeune pour écouter.
D'accord, OK.
Mais oui, un truc qui me frappe, c'est que voilà, vous êtes passés pour ma podcast.
De temps en temps, vous faites des spéciales.
Ouais.
Vous aviez fait, il y a un ou deux ans, une spéciale cinéma belge.
Ouais, il y a deux ans.
Vous aviez reçu, voilà, les frères Dardenne, par exemple.
Oui.
Quelque chose qui m'avait frappé, c'est qu'on parle de cinéma belge, mais en fait, on ne parle que de cinéma belge francophone.
On amène les distributeurs, on parle un petit peu de ce qui est tax shelter, etc.
Ça, c'était le préalable de l'émission qu'on avait mis sur pied. C'était à l'occasion des cinquante ans de l'aide à la production au cinéma en Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles.
Ouais.
Donc dès le moment où on parle du cinéma francophone belge et de ces cinquante ans, entre guillemets, il n'y avait aucune raison d'inviter Matthias Schoenaerts.
Certes, mais ce que j'essaie d'évoquer par là, c'est que, que ce soit dans la spéciale ou dans Cinq Heures Cinéma en général, et c'est quelque chose que je comprends très bien, mais là, j'ai envie d'en parler,
assez peu de cinéma flamand.
Mais non, c'est faux. Pas moins que de cinéma australien. S'il y a une sortie, on en parle.
Sauf si le film ne sort qu'en Flandre. Nous, on s'adresse aux gens qui sont susceptibles d'aller au cinéma à Bruxelles et en Wallonie.
Ouais.
Il y a des tas de films, on en a encore parlé la semaine dernière, notamment des films qui viennent de chez Plopsaland, les Kadri...
Oui, bon, ça, c'est autre chose, hein, oui.
Ben non, c'est autre chose, mais c'est pour illustrer ce que—
Ouais
...ce que je suis en train de démontrer, c'est que ces films-là ne sortent même pas à Bruxelles ni en Wallonie. Il n'y a aucune raison d'en parler.
Par contre, quand c'est un film comme Black, quand c'est un film comme, je sais plus, ces trucs qui évoquaient les tueurs du Brabant wallon, là, récemment.
Voilà. Mais tous ces films, dès qu'ils sont distribués, soit doublés ou sous-titrés du côté, dans le sud du pays, de Bruxelles et Wallonie, on en parle comme d'une sortie de la semaine.
Je t'avoue que je suis un peu surpris, mais enfin, ce que j'essaie d'évoquer—
C'est que tu n'écoutes pas.
J'écoute sans écouter. Non, ce que j'essaie d'évoquer, c'est un petit peu le phénomène Stan Van Samang, tu vois ? Est-ce que tu te souviens de Stan Van Samang ?
Oui, très bien.
Voilà. Donc c'est le phénomène des Bekende Vlamingen.
Oui.
Où on a des rock stars qui remplissent des stades—
Ben oui
...en Flandre. Et moi-même, toi-même, jamais entendu parler.
Non.
Et puis voilà, j'étais il y a quelques années dans le bureau de Universal à Zaventem et je vois énormes affiches pour Stan Van Samang.
Ouais, tout à fait.
Moi, j'ai le sentiment que c'est un petit peu la même chose pour le cinéma.
Comme au dernier...
au dernier MIA, là, il y a un gars qui a ramassé quatre MIA, j'ai même oublié son nom, qui fait une espèce de chanson populaire en flamand,
un peu du Clouseau, comme ça, mais tout seul, qui est un gars qui a présenté des émissions pour les enfants sur Ketnet, parce que je me suis fait un peu expliquer qui était ce gars.
Ensuite, il a joué dans des séries en Flandre. Maintenant, il chante. Et ce gars, c'est trois Sportpaleis sur un week-end, les doigts dans le nez, à l'aise.
Voilà, il y a une ferveur populaire—
Mmh
...flamande pour ce type d'artiste flamand. Bah tant mieux pour eux. Voilà. Quel est l'intérêt pour nous, diffuseurs, de diffuser ce type d'artiste pour nos publics ?
Honnêtement, je le vois pas.
Mmh.
Ça n'apporte pas grand-chose,
au dossier. Par contre, je comprends très bien pour la Flandre, qui est en pénurie d'artistes qui chantent dans leur langue, alors que nous, il suffit de se baisser pour ramasser avec tout ce qui vient de France et même d'ailleurs.
En Flandre, je comprends que la personne qui chante en flamand reste quand même une denrée relativement rare et c'est une denrée qui doit être préservée et cultivée.
Oui. Une frontière restera, implicitement, entre les films flamands et les films belges francophones parce que ça n'intéresse pas trop le public côté francophone et que ça n'arrive pas dans les oreilles du Wallon.
Donc, pourquoi pousser quoi ?
Franchement, c'est une question d'Ancien Belge—
Ouais, mais tout à fait
...que tu poses. Mais alors, on peut le regretter ou pas. Voilà. Pourquoi est-ce qu'il y a les Ensor et les Magritte ?
Pourquoi il y a les MIA et les D6bels Music Awards ? C'est quoi ce pays ? C'est quoi ce foutoir ? Pourquoi est-ce qu'on ne rassemble pas tout le monde dans une seule et même grande soirée et tout ?
Ben parce que c'est pas possible. Voilà.
Ouais.
Parce que c'est deux cultures, mais complètement différentes, deux approches complètement différentes.
Mmh.
Voilà, les uns peuvent s'inspirer des autres, mais...
Le truc le plus emblématique de ça, c'est quand même The Voice Belgique, côté RTBF, et The Voice van Vlaanderen, côté VRT.
Mais bref, voilà, on va peut-être pas épiloguer là-dessus. C'est constat, quoi.
Ça aussi, il y a peut-être, voilà, une analyse de sémantique à faire de ce côté-là qui est sans doute révélatrice de quelque chose quoi, que la radio jeune de la VRT s'appelle Studio Brussel.
Pourquoi Bruxelles ?
Oui, alors que 92 % de Bruxellois sont francophones—
Et depuis que la N-VA pense que le retrait de Bruxelles, que c'est— enfin, voilà, il y a un retrait de— il faut arrêter d'investir sur Bruxelles, ça sert à rien, retour à Anvers, etc.
Et comme par hasard, maintenant, la radio s'appelle StuBru et plus Studio Bruxelles. Enfin— mais tout ça, ce sont des signaux qu'il faut arriver à décoder pour un petit peu comprendre dans quelle pièce on joue.
Yes. Quelque chose qui m'a frappé aussi quand je lisais, recommandé par Cinq Heures en préparant cette émission, c'est que, du temps où tu étais directeur de la chaîne, tu recommandais aux animateurs : surtout,
surtout, ne faites pas comme nous.
Ben oui.
Ne faites pas du Cinq Heures Cinéma.
Alors que, ben à côté de ça, on se dit : mais plus d'un million de téléchargements par an. François Jadoul disait sur Twitter : podcast belge francophone le plus écouté.
Oui. On est le podcast belge, donc belge, ici hein, national, cinéma le plus écouté devant les podcasts flamands.
Cinéma, oui. Là, tu casses un petit peu, tu te places dans une niche.
Je crois tout podcast confondu, on est 16 ou 17.
Oui. Oui, c'est clairement ce qu'on regarde.
Ce dont on n'a pas à rougir. Et en cinéma, on est le devant des podcasts flamands. Tout ça pour dire quoi ?
Oui, ah oui. Donc, tu disais à ton écurie d'animateurs chez Pure FM : Surtout, ne faites pas comme nous.
Mais non, parce que c'est un produit, enfin, c'est un écosystème Cinq Heures, d'abord, un qui existe depuis 25 ans et qui est totalement spécifique.
Et le jour où Hugues ou moi, on arrête, personne ne va reprendre l'émission, c'est impossible.
Non, c'est clair.
Ben oui, elle est directement liée à notre manière de faire les choses. Donc, ça ne sert à rien d'essayer de faire ce qu'on fait.
Si on le fait, c'est parce que c'est nous et on n'est pas du tout exemplatif. Surtout pas. Il faut surtout pas essayer de faire ce qu'on fait.
Genre, don't try this at home quoi, tu vois ? Voilà.
Oui, mais ça veut aussi un petit peu dire que voilà, ben le jour où Hugues ou toi, vous arrêtez—
Oui.
Qu'est-ce qui sera là pour remplacer ? Est-ce que la RTBF a pour ambition de créer une—
J'en sais rien. Il faut aller demander à monsieur RTBF ou madame RTBF.
Mais toi, en tant que directeur de chaîne, tu n'étais pas en train de te dire : on va préparer la suite.
Non.
On va préparer la relève, non ?
Non, non. Non, mais sur ce projet-là en particulier, c'est absolument impossible. C'est directement lié à la personnalité de Hugues et à la mienne et à la rencontre des deux.
Non, mais je ne parlais pas de reprendre Cinq Heures Cinéma en particulier, mais on aurait pu imaginer une autre émission talk où on parle sur les disques ou,
ou voilà, ça aurait pu être— je sais que Cinq Heures Cinéma avait été remplacé pendant un temps par
Café Comédie avec Raphaël Charrier.
Oui, parce qu'on continuait en podcast, oui. Donc il fallait— donc alors, c'est la case qui avait été comblée par autre chose, mais Café Comédie ne remplaçait pas Cinq Heures.
Non, oui.
C'est juste la case—
Je ne parlais pas de remplacer, mais je parlais de continuer dans cette idée de talk, service public, blagues, un peu, voilà, un peu second degré.
Aujourd'hui, la RTBF ne produit plus des contenus comme ça. Est-ce que c'est pas un peu dommage ?
J'en sais rien.
Je sais pas, tu es amateur de ton propre contenu, j'imagine. Donc, est-ce que c'est pas un petit peu dommage de se dire : « Aujourd'hui, voilà, homme de radio, maintenant, j'écoute surtout Spotify.
Homme de Cinq Heures Cinéma, quand j'aurai fini, il y aura plus rien. » Est-ce qu'on n'y perd pas un peu ?
Alors, j'ai pas dit : quand j'aurai fini, il y aura plus rien. Il y aura d'autres choses, mais qui ne seront pas une imitation de ce que nous, on a fait avant.
Ce n'est pas ce que je voulais dire non plus.
Voilà.
Qu'est-ce qu'il y aura alors comme autre chose ?
J'en sais rien.
Moi, je ne vois pas.
Je suis pas devin. Voilà, et peut-être des choses qui ne m'intéresseront pas moi parce que ça sera pas de mon âge.
Oui.
Voilà, il existe peut-être même des tas de trucs, voilà, je n'ai pas non plus la prétention d'avoir une connaissance exhaustive de tout ce qui existe et de tout ce qui se fait et d'avoir un avis sur tout.
Il y a certainement des choses formidables qui se font et qui existent et je n'ai pas assez de temps dans une journée pour—
Si c'est le cas, en tout cas, on s'en fout.
Je sais pas. Il y a parfois des gens qui se manifestent avec des choses comme ça, mais voilà, rien de...
Non ?
Non, mais en même temps, c'est pas un jugement de valeur, hein, c'est en disant : non, il y a rien, c'est fini, il y a plus rien.
Je suis pas du tout comme ça.
C'est pas ce que je faisais non plus.
Non, mais je pense que de toute façon, aujourd'hui, quelqu'un qui débarque avec un projet comme Cinq Heures, il prend la porte quoi.
Et c'est normal. C'est tellement hors format, c'est tellement sur orbite, c'est tellement—
Tu dis c'est normal et en même temps, Cinq Heures cartonne. Donc on se dit : il y a quand même...
Mais oui, mais c'est parce qu'il y a une—
Un public pour ça.
Il y a une longévité, une antériorité. On a construit quelque chose lentement, lentement, pendant des années.
Donc est-ce que ça veut dire qu'en 95, quand Cinq Heures commence, on donnait sa chance à un projet comme celui-là ?
Probablement.
Et qu'aujourd'hui, plus vraiment ?
Peut-être, oui.
Oui. Mais ce n'était pas que—
C'est pas grave ?
Moi, j'existe toujours avec ce projet et Hugues, 25 ans après, c'est qu'on a réussi à passer entre les gouttes.
J'en sais rien. C'est qu'à un moment donné— tu sais, dans l'émission, je l'explique dans le bouquin, l'émission Cinq Heures, elle durait cinq heures et Hugues intervenait,
pour une fraction de cinq à dix minutes pour venir parler des sorties de la semaine.
Ces cinq minutes sont devenues une demi-heure, la demi-heure est devenue une heure. Mais en gros, Hugues m'avait été imposé parce que l'émission avait lieu le mercredi.
On m'avait dit : « Le mercredi, tu dois parler cinéma, tu reçois Hugues Dayez. » Je me suis dit : Oh non, pitié, il est pas marrant.
Le projet n'a pas été pitché comme un truc où on va parler sur les disques et où on va—
Non, mais c'est pour te dire qu'on ne peut jamais prévoir. C'est un peu la théorie du chaos en mathématiques, c'est-à-dire que tout est prévu sauf l'imprévu.
Et tout ce qui existait autour de Cinq Heures, ce sont des choses qui avaient été voulues. La seule chose qui m'avait été imposée dont je ne voulais pas, c'est Hugues.
Là, on est en, ouais—
95 ?
Oui.
Dans ces eaux-là ?
Dans ces eaux-là. Aujourd'hui, tout a disparu sauf Hugues. Donc seul l'imprévu a réussi à traverser le temps et arriver jusqu'ici, jusqu'en 2019.
Ouais. Donc préparer la relève, en fait, ça ne peut pas se faire parce que ça ne se prépare pas. C'est l'imprévu.
Bah oui, il y a peut-être des gens, là, qui sont en train de préparer quelque chose au moment où on se parle et on n'est pas au courant et tout le monde va faire : « Waouh !
» Je sais pas, peut-être que la relève, elle doit venir de— peut-être pas de la radio, d'ailleurs.
Je me suis laissé entraîner au King—
C'est pas faux d'ailleurs.
...au Kings of Comedy avec Alex Vizorek, là, pendant qu'on travaille ensemble sur les Magritte. Et j'ai entendu deux, trois humoristes que je trouvais vraiment sympas, que je connaissais pas du tout. Voilà.
Fanny Ruwet fait du stand-up maintenant.
Oui.
Ce sera peut-être elle, la relève.
J'ai entendu. Oui, peut-être.
Très bien, mais on va tout doucement clôturer puisqu'on a un petit peu dépassé les septante minutes.
Dernière question, question qui m'est hautement personnelle : comment ça se fait que ça fait cinq ans que chaque année en novembre, vous nous dites : « L'année prochaine, on fait un réveillon » ?
Mais je vais te raconter la véritable histoire du réveillon. C'est que quand j'étais à la tête de Pure, je demandais à chaque fois aux équipes, vers septembre, octobre, par là : « Bon, qui a un projet de réveillon ?
» Et en fait, personne n'avait de projet de réveillon. Sans doute pas envie de bosser, pas envie de bosser en direct un soir de réveillon ou même en différé.
En fait, pas envie de faire ça. Donc, avec Hugues, par défaut, on faisait le réveillon. Et pour finir, à chaque fois que je demandais, personne ne répondait.
Je demandais plus et on faisait systématiquement—
...un réveillon, un réveillon alternatif tous les deux—
Ouais.
...qui durait quatre heures. On a fait ça, je crois, pendant sept années consécutives. Et un jour, j'ai dit : « Maintenant, j'en ai marre.
Vous allez vous débrouiller et vous allez faire votre réveillon. En tout cas, Hugues et moi, cette année, on ne le fait pas.
Donc, trouvez quelque chose. Amenez des disques, amenez du gâteau, amenez des blagues, amenez des invités, amenez des paillettes, amenez du champagne.
Nous n'en ameniez pas, mais en tout cas, on ne fera pas ce réveillon. »
Voilà.
Donc il y avait une soirée direct, effectivement, avec toute l'équipe ce soir-là.
Voilà. Ça a été ma dernière contribution au réveillon. Et après, j'ai dit : « À vous de voir ».
Ouais, ouais, ouais. Mais tu promets quand même depuis quelques années : « Ça va, on va le faire, on va le faire ».
Non, mais on fera certainement un jour un réveillon en live quelque part, une espèce de COD réveillon, mais pas un truc en radio, mais on le fera dans un endroit—
Il n'y aura pas le retour de Good day today de Lacher—
Lacher aussi, il y aura tout ça. On amènera—
En live.
...Niel Lacher en live. Oui, oui, bien sûr.
Mais plus rien, plus rien en radio, plus rien. Parce que donc le—
Mais j'en sais rien si— peut-être. Peut-être qu'on reviendra en radio.
En radio ou en podcast, c'est pas—
Peut-être qu'on reviendra en radio et en podcast—
...et en live.
Si ça ne te disait rien, je dirais : « OK ». Mais de fait, c'est quelque chose que tu utilises depuis longtemps et puis chaque année, c'est : « Bon, allez, l'année prochaine ».
Donc j'ai envie de te demander : est-ce que c'est ton ambition ou pas ?
De se faire un réveillon ?
De me faire un réveillon ou de faire un réveillon pour les auditeurs, puisque c'est quelque chose dont tu parles.
Oui, oui, on le fera certainement un jour.
Pourquoi est-ce que vous ne l'avez toujours pas fait alors ?
Bah parce qu'on crée l'attente, voilà.
Ouais, c'est ça. Très bien. Rudy, c'était un plaisir de passer Septante Minutes Avec toi.
Eh bien, moi aussi.
Chers auditeurs, on se retrouve dans deux semaines.
Chers auditeurs.
C'est marrant parce que t'es en podcast et tu te fais : « Hey » pour commencer et tu termines en disant : « Chers auditeurs ».
Qu'est-ce que— vas-y, dis-moi ce que je dois faire.
Moi, je fais semblant de savoir ce que je fais hein mais—
Ouais, non, non. Tu dis, tu dis, mais—
Je rote et puis je fais : « Bon, allez, salut hein ».
Ah non, j'ai pas dit ça. Non, non, non. Ah non, non, j'ai pas dit qu'il fallait être impoli, mais chers auditeurs est quand même une manière un petit peu désuète et—
Désuète ?
Oui, oui, d'un autre temps, de saluer les gens qui écoutent quoi.
Tu dis : « Ah, je me fais traiter de vieux ».
Non, non, non, mais comme quoi,
ça rejoint ce que je disais tout à l'heure, c'est que le podcast, en fait, rebondit sur des ressorts d'une radio et d'une grand-mère de radio qui ont été abandonnés, mais qui ont existé il y a longtemps.
Honnêtement, je sais même pas si j'ai déjà entendu quelqu'un à la radio dire : « Chers auditeurs » pour terminer le truc.
Ça fait un peu BBC quand ils terminent le programme à la télé et qu'il y a une voix off qui parle sur le générique pour dire : « Et dans un instant, vous retrouverez Fanny Ruwet pour animer l'actualité ».
Mais donc, je t'ai coupé dans ton élan et dans ton envol.
Non, mais c'est parfait.
Donc, chers auditeurs—
Ouais.
...et puis puisqu'on est moderne, et chères auditrices.
Tout à fait. On se retrouve dans deux semaines pour un nouvel épisode de Septante Minutes Avec. Au revoir. C'est déjà tout pour ce Septante Minutes Avec Rudy Léonet.
On rappelle que son magnifique podcast s'appelle Cinq Heures Cinéma et qu'un nouvel épisode sort tous les mardis. Dans deux semaines, sauf imprévu, je publierai l'interview de Frédéric Martel.
Frédéric Martel, c'est ce journaliste qui a infiltré le Vatican et a enquêté pendant quatre ans sur la communauté homosexuelle en son sein.
On parlera, entre autres, de la sublimation par les prêtres, de leur sexualité et de comment ça a indirectement mené à ce que des actes pédophiles soient couverts.
Voilà, comme ça, au moins, on varie un petit peu les sujets. N'oubliez pas de vous abonner au podcast sur votre plateforme de podcast préférée, que ce soit iTunes, YouTube, Spotify, Pocket Cast, tout ce que vous voulez.
J'ai aussi mis les liens dans la description vers tous les réseaux sociaux. Comme ça, vous êtes sûrs de ne rien manquer.
Allez, à dans deux semaines. Salut !